I heard that you followed around a
supervisor he works as similar care
facility to you working in the film
through a shift who ended how only
opening was burnt and what was the best
advice that she gave you
it was extremely eye-opening I mean I
think without her realizing it it not
only informed Grace and the film but it
informed my life I mean I took I took
from it really huge life lessons that I
had yet to learn because she is the calm
and the storm of these children that are
really struggling and are also in this
constant push back because they are not
used to trusting anyone and they are
trying to do everything in their power
to get you to snap so that you can be
just like everybody else and she had
this beautiful balance and how she would
push forward and when she would let off
and when I just I was in awe of the
whole thing and she had this very calm
demeanor that everything was very
matter-of-fact and she had done this job
for 20 years something something crazy
and so I asked her after many hours of
just sitting there you know a game just
couldn't believe how how perfectly I
felt she was handling these situations
and I asked her how she did it and she
just said you let go and it was the
simplest and most profound advice I had
ever received and this is coming from my
job is to kind of emotionally turn up
some stuff in my head and then put it on
on camera and I had found in the past
anytime I had gone into some some
treacherous territory some harder
material a darker character I could film
a movie for two weeks a month but then
it would take me three months to a year
to undo the damage that I had done to
myself psychologically you know I'd make
myself believe these things or I'd
remind myself of things that I didn't
need to you know most people heal but I
just keep them there to just turn it up
and I realized how unhealthy that was
and how important it is for me is my
growth as an adult to learn the
separation and the emotional separation
so it allowed me this great
opportunity to go really deep and really
far within this character but then when
the day was done I was able to remove
myself from it and decompress and relax
and laugh and find joy and bliss and the
hard work that had been done but no need
to linger in it it's not any great for
the film obviously but in terms of your
career as an actress as well yeah in
terms of you being exactly in terms of
just my mental health it was absolutely
incredible because what she's dealing
with this is so much more than what than
what I'm doing and it was I feel like
she saved me from a lot of of trouble
later on a you pandey both work and in
life in the film Mason played by John
can I get Julia now I heard that it's
the director Destin set you little task
he went on to do it together and so you
a late date any day you look pass today
no one did need to tell me a little bit
about what that involved yeah it was
pretty genius um we didn't have very
much time because we're a very small
film really really low budget and with
everyone's schedules it was kind of put
together really quickly and we didn't
have any time for rehearsal but the
importance there's this underlying
importance of the film that there are
these long relationships and including
the one between Grace and Mason they've
been together for many years and it's
not something that has really shown very
much in the film but it's something that
has kind of felt and understood and so
being able to get that level of of
comfort and of understanding between the
two of them the with the time frame that
we had the only thing John and I could
do was go to dinner so we had planned
this dinner and in Destin I guess found
out about it and as John was leaving to
meet me at the restaurant he saw an
envelope on his doorstep that was
labeled to the two of us and said do not
open until you get to the restaurant and
so we is this thing and we open it up
and inside it had this little letter
from Dustin that just said you know oh
wow this is gonna help you but I'm
trying here and inside it were a bunch
of little pieces of paper that were
conversation starters and they
things ranging from specifics about
asking us to open up to each other about
our childhoods about our favorite
childhood memories or hopes and fears of
being a parent those sort of bigger
questions and then just getting a
dialogue going between Grace and Mason
what was our first date like how long
have we been dating and then it got to
the point we got really even interested
in our finances of figuring out okay
well for making this much a month maybe
this is why you know I have a bike and
we only have one car and maybe we moved
in together really quickly because you
know we started to create and the next
thing you know we're like arguing over
where are like $20 of spending money is
going and it really worked it created
something that we had an entire
mythology we had a whole catalogue of
information about each other and about
how those two characters related and and
it just it really worked I mean I think
you complete you I mean it's not
something that you are you have told in
the film but you feel it yeah you guys
have this very few yeah there's very few
scenes actually where the two of them
are really intimately together and it's
interesting that you see it's just
really just one scene briefly of them
together and somehow it carries you
through this whole thing and you feel
for them and relate to them and I don't
think that it would have been possible
if we hadn't had that conversation and
one of the things going to so good ants
is it's reading situations reading
people when she first meets them in a
long time as well how good would you say
you are at that in real life
um I don't know I don't know I think
probably somewhere in the middle maybe
it's hard the thing that the thing that
I really enjoy about being a human being
and my job in particular is listening I
love listening much more than I like
talking and I don't really enjoy talking
about myself so having the opportunity
within this film where it felt like so
much of my job was just listening
listening to the kids listening and
reading a situation and being totally
quiet and just registering and living
within that and it made my job really
easy that everyone I was listening to
were really good actors and I didn't
feel like my job really had
do very much with creating something in
my head as it was just being present and
looking at someone and caring and
feeling about them and even and that all
leads up to you know a scene where I
talk with my boss about about one child
in particular and I'm really fighting
for her and it was a big moment for me
because I never for a second was
fighting for some imaginary idea of a
child if I did I really cared so much I
cared so much about Caitlyn I get so
much about these kids and I cared so
much about the kids that I met while
shadowing that it felt it felt real to
me I felt like I was really going
through the motions with her and and
that was a pretty pretty cool feeling
and he's interesting we say about some
both yourself on your character being a
listener or the talker because it kind
of reminds me as well of a very
different of course / but a very
different current you've got in the
London Film Fest as well your character
and donjon oh yeah feel that because
she's very much an observer as well as
she is yeah oh yeah totally totally I
mean that's all she's doing the whole
time and that's someone who very much
recognizes that she's gonna say
something and it just makes everyone
argue more and no one's gonna listen to
it and so instead she just sits there
having this knowledge and she's just
strange she becomes a strange character
and that because she is in some ways I
feel like what the audiences feeling as
they're watching it I felt like it maybe
it's just because it's me and the
audience watching it but I felt like I
was making the same faces in my seat
watching it as I was on screen because
that she's kind of giving she's the one
inside her she's the one person for us
that we look to him we're going like
okay so this is weird like everyone we
can all recognize as a very strange and
these people that are all talking and
arguing have such strong opinions that
think that they're right or in reality
sometimes it really is the person that
doesn't feel the need to say anything
but is the quiet observer that's kind of
cataloging everything that those are the
ones those are the ones I mean you have
a fantastic position
cause obviously it's short turn 12 one
of them it's one of my top phones in the
EMA study and I can see Hollywood's
definitely gonna come knocking let's not
pretend that and what would you say if
somebody like JJ was came to said how
about Salisbury I think that I would pee
my pants okay that's about it there's no
there's there's I mean those movies are
everything to me
and I think JJ Abrams is he is in a lot
of ways where I take some of my cues
because I am a huge huge believer and
fighting the hard fight for the mystery
to stay within this industry and it's
really hard when movies are bizarre and
they're strange and they are kind of fun
to talk about but it's really important
and it's important for my job as an
actor in particular to keep certain
things hidden because it just doesn't
become fun anymore I remember wanting to
be a magician as a kid and it was all I
wanted I want it and I didn't want to be
the assistant I wanted to be the
magician and then this TV show I don't
know if it came out here but this this
TV show came out called like magicians
secrets revealed and it was like the
highest televised thing and then and it
was devastating because all of the great
secrets all of the things that we loved
the illusions were gone they had taken
them you know this guy had taken them
away and I feel like there's a similar
aspect to the magic of creating a movie
is there are some beautiful aspects of
it there are some really talented people
that I work with that I'd love to talk
about but there's a certain point where
it's so important that people don't know
about me they don't know about my life
they don't know about how I feel about
certain things because it it will in the
end only stop the idea that I can then
transition into being another face with
another mask talking about losing the
magical or keeping the magic if you were
passing something like story she'd be
seeing the kind of behind the scenes
wouldn't you be part of that world being
created and it's - son of leaves money
in a way yeah I don't know though I mean
that that whole thing to me it does it
that holds those movies to me are really
really important
it's like one
books that I read on the making of a
movie was the making of Star Wars and I
got it from the library when I was eight
years old and I thought it was so cool
that I like knew how they did the
lightsaber so and it's that mean it's
just the ultimate it's the ultimate
hero's journey so I mean I don't know I
I don't know I mean in my mind like I
want to be in Star Wars and I want to be
in Indiana Jones I want to be in Star
Trek and I want to be I mean I would
love those movies yeah I want to be a
superhero I want to be in Terminator and
did I miss anybody
yeah maybe Laura Croft - Oh throw her
and I just I I loved those movies I
think that they're as much as something
like scenes from a marriage is
incredibly important to me
Star Wars isms are Lord of the Rings
Lord of the Rings those ones are kind of
in the same category for me is I mean
the budgets are very different we're
talking about much different scripts and
a much different sort of facade but at
the end of the day it's still the same
thing and we're talking about humans and
humans struggle and the world being a
magical place and that's that's what
it's all about
they breathe in the lovely talking to
you we look for lots of thank you
you